what was your all-time favorite Weasley
twin shenanigan over the course of all
the movies
the joke shop in the sixth movie
that was my favorite uh because the set
was amazing and it was all about us
which every actor wants her
yep all right what was your least
favorite scene to shoot on Harry Potter
whether it was just hard it was long it
was boring ugh
there would be least favorite scene
quidditch in the third movie because it
was it was blues or green screen and
these things can take a while anyway
because they need to match up with all
the other uh effects that were going on
but it was set in the rain so we were
soaking wet we had a giant like fan
meant blowing at you what made you look
like you're flying so that was cold
um yeah that's I think I shuddered when
I think about it both physically and
metaphorically James
uh least favorite probably would be the
uh
sixth movie when the Weasley house is on
fire because that was night shoots for
about
two weeks and it was cold and wet and
all those kind of fun things which no
one realizes goes on when you're filming